[Music]
you know don't touch my property news
submitted by better call Saul oh yeah
you guys have a big reaction of that
okay officers using chalk on tires for
parking enforcement may be violating the
Constitution no one does the founding
fathers when they wrote that they were
like what okay we got the whole like
arms and like freedom
what about tie it shot what about the do
we do the parking stuff guys I think
that's important I mean they do that
they check your hours right could they
come by they mark it and then they go up
yeah car two though expensive yeah and
you just got them like buffed and waxed
or whatever they do to time the hell are
you saying
yeah usually sand excuse me can you make
sure to sad my stuff down you say though
made sense but boss my tires can you
make them look shiny okay what did they
put up on the wall I don't know but tire
dressing on it would you like it just
the tire dressing now you're [ __ ]
backing him up goes nicely on piyah
salad this woman she just kept getting a
[ __ ] ton of parking tickets and it was
mainly from this one parking officer she
lived in Hollywood with my 12 signs all
contradict each other yes I [ __ ] hate
that for real
no this is in Michigan so this woman her
name was Alison she said that it was
unconstitutional for a parking
enforcement officer to be talking her
private property in the Constitution
because of the Fourth Amendment so for
the Fourth Amendment it's
as it protects people from unreasonable
searches and seizures and to in order to
determine whether your violation has
occurred the court has to first ask
whether the government's conduct counts
as a search and if so that's when you
asked if the search was reasonable but
what they're doing here with the
chalking they're saying that they are
trespassing on pone privately owned
vehicles parked on a public street to
place the chalk mark in order to gather
information to ultimately impose a
government-sanctioned amazing after all
these years it took one woman to change
the game because even the judges and
everyone was like oh you know what you
tried that give you that - when you put
two opposite magnetism oh oh yeah no
it's okay he's passed he loves the women
that's what it was well yes so this is a
three-judge panel of the US Court of
Appeals and they all unanimously agreed
I'm happy because that means they can't
do that [ __ ] anymore yeah I know but
it's just like they got better [ __ ] to
do it yeah I feel like there's like
other things to do I guess it's probably
another way they can track the time now
so that's what they're saying now the oh
here is the photo cuz they're not
touching the car but they could still
determine where the car is please it's
okay I think for me I just want to stick
it to home because I'm just like ha I
have a small victory yeah and then the
woman [ __ ] Ellison was saying that I
think that for her I mean obviously
she's super happy that this went through
but the really cool part and the most
exciting part for her is that in the
future law students will get to read
about her case when they're studying the
Fourth Amendment
loyal like just no I just say this is
like the first of its kind just a law in
thoose East well you know we get all
these you're like you know what I'm
gonna do I'm gonna go to the
Constitution yeah like we know little
steps yeah she's gotta be some sort of
law he memorized it oh well she's petty
as well I tried I tried but she still
got the job done straight up my ex put
the Constitution out of me to always
think a woman will not stand down if you
think something is we fight for [ __ ]
that matter
that's what I was saying guys that's
what I was saying it's do this right
yeah okay yeah not to add to you well I
mean cuz I I immediately thought if the
talk wouldn't work then the picture
would like though just for sure so the
the parking enforcement officer my name
is Tabatha and so Allison said that all
13 of her tickets did I mention that she
got 15 earlier yes she got them from
Tavis - that came from 15 tickets just
like I'm not paying for this [ __ ] I'm
just gonna make this illegal that's
genius
are you imagine now it is nice what
would be a real win if if they took off
hat out completely so then people
wouldn't be able to they wouldn't be
able to enforce the [ __ ] parking laws
he'll be dope well actually not really
cuz they what if you really need a park
so yeah okay we need them to keep
[ __ ] enforcing the laws that is
Tabatha I know when my name was Allison
is Allison did the right thing because
they're not marking up your tires
anymore Thanks the ones I just put that
have you guys ever had your tires mark
cuz I don't I see it you do Pasadena
they market tires all the time but not I
can't
yeah I wish a [ __ ] and the beach
cities you ever want to go to Manhattan
Beach to ride bikes when I came back I
saw Oh what color chalk did they use a
white head coats coats of the dressing
oh yeah higher addressing Lydia how does
it work if it's like hella greasy no no
they do it on the tray
the tie not on the side not on the wall
I just don't like the way that looks
doing a train at a time when you drive
off isn't it clear what not always and
then I always see it like if there's a
good piece of track it's kind of like
tissue stuck on the bottom of your chute
just doesn't look attractive you don't
want that on your car my car is covered
in water spots right now because the
sprinkler just [ __ ] hits it but my
tires are shiny has got the nice grease
on it mmm a shitty car dude Oh matter
anymore yeah I mean element
all right about that car did you could
hose those down from the inside that's
the only thing I know about them yup me
too
came in handy a few times camping trips
I gotta tell you right now that car I
can give a [ __ ] less about it and it
feels nice quite nice somebody's dead
today yesterday it was great
you don't care they just opened it up
with boom and they were like I'm so
sorry I was like dude my catalytic
converter got stolen and I had a replace
that and that was worth more than the
actual car well that sucks
so apparently Honda elements are really
easy to steal the catalytic converter I
don't think anyone surprised it's a
Honda and it's already lifted up so they
could just pop that [ __ ] right out your
people tend to steal it a lot in LA
we're creative or thieves women your
womenkind he's gay doesn't like I am of
the game yeah I am of the game yeah yeah
but people just dent the car all the
time I think it's all just because the
[ __ ] I don't know what the steel is
on the car is just [ __ ] it's like super
weak supposed to be made to bent and
kick in like a 30 no I'm like all
seriousness isn't supposed to be like
just like kick around Ryloth we both
would be like made to last at all dude
because I've noticed like so many dents
over the past like two years I've had it
and it's like the top away of cause yeah
son a little too long kind of melt
look at it and then the sigh just goes
you have a mismatch the door to it
you're like this doesn't fit where the
for the [ __ ] when I leave my garage
like is that a really steep incline I
could feel the whole car shake you try
to take it off rody
absolutely not mom or with a car frame I
went to the [ __ ] desert and there was
a 30 mile per hour wind and the [ __ ]
car was full off goes like this what are
you crazy the funnier part is Bart kept
telling him not to get this I still love
the car though hey seems happy yeah who
are you to say I just don't know why I
love the car so you bought it for $2,000
I bought it for 12,000 now it's worth
2,000 like you paid for it
yeah oh I see we're saying 3ish grand
and then it took like four grand to fix
it oh my gosh dude so seven thousand see
which business it's actually if I sell
it like privately it's worth more than
what I put into it so could I guess that
[ __ ] else is gonna buy this one William
Hung it's [ __ ] bad at math and
business it is [ __ ] hard to find a
good hunt element did it's hard do you
grant that's a steal because my Honda
Element has less than 90 K miles on it
is there a Honda Element community yeah
if you just notice around it's hard to
believe you have a woman in your life
it's hard to believe you're an actual
woman no one else thinks that don't you
[ __ ] write those come on [ __ ] write
those comments
oh I Drive a sick Lancer with a big wing
on it
[ __ ] evil like the exhaust well my
catalytic converter that's Tomatoes but
like it's not hers I pay for with the
checks they make from the bank I work at
but I got fired from Wow
but it is my car I Drive it all the time
the wing I pay for myself the wing is is
like the main part oh how big is the
wing super big super big it's like big
too big for the car arguably but like it
just drives on two wheels that are
certain plushies the trunk under the
weight of the downforce it's pretty sick
the trunks also just crushed cuz I
backed into the hood that's the story I
tell from the big wing mmm downforce
science in other news my car is sick
[Music]
[Music]